hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unlee chess yesterday we
played a very nice game but at a crucial
opponent we blundered piece we were
still able to win the game but it
required some flagging of our opponent
so hopefully today I will not have to
resort to such tactics and uh let's just
play a nice nice clean game if possible
so 10 minutes per player only only
playing high rated opponents let's see
who we face this round it is uh Lena p
uh country unknown let's open with E4 as
we did in the previous games and we have
an E5 so we might even end up in an
Evans Gambit who knows Knight to C6 we
have Bishop to C4 just a nice Italian
game and uh yeah let's see if it will be
the two knights or the or the or or the
bishop C5 line that seems like it's a
it's a great decision Big Moment In the
game uh yeah it's it's a bishop C5 and
we will go for the Evans gamut let's go
for B4 all right last game I employed
the EV EV I lost uh so I'm not very
happy about that but I always say what
what are the chances of losing two Evans
Gambit games in a row and for those of
you who are maybe just uh starting your
chess Journey it's a very nice opening
you give up a pawn and then you gain all
um uh just a lot of development with C3
and D4 and you have a very rapid
development of your pieces if uh you
know you you play well and the standard
moves are Bishop A5 Bishop to C5 Bishop
to E7 uh possible or also Bishop to D6
Bishop to f8 not so much but yeah
usually yeah Bishop to E7 or Bishop to
A5 will be played and Bishop to E7 is
better in my opinion because once you
play Bishop to A5 you no longer have
Knight to A5 and Knight to A5 is a a
critical defensive resource against the
Evans Gambit since I will put my queen
on B3 and Knight A5 will go after the
queen and the bishop if you play Bishop
back to A5 then you will have to waste a
move with Bishop to B6 but it's still
perfectly fine you can play it uh okay
so so Pawn is captured here and uh we
have to decide Queen B3 is very nice
going for the pawn uh right away or we
could Castle to safety we're going to go
with Queen to B3
first see what our opponent does and
this is a uh now a moment where our
opponent has to play Knight to A5 it
looks very odd because you have to give
up the F7 Pawn but that's just how this
line is played there there's no other
way to do it at least I think yeah
Knight Knight A5 we're going to capture
on F7
and uh next we're going to play uh Queen
to A4 and go after the Knight as our our
Bishop will be attacked um uh also a
nice way to blender here with white is
to play Queen to B5 instead because you
think okay King captures the bishop
we're going to capture the Knight H but
then C6 attacks your queen and defends
the Knight and you're in trouble so you
have to play Queen to
A4 all right so we're going to go for
that
um I don't know if uh it's possible not
to take the bishop here maybe even just
defending the Knight with B6 is possible
but I don't think it's uh yeah I don't
think it's it's the
best and now something like D6 should be
played simply to avoid any Knight to E5
ideas in the future uh but yeah it's
white black is always very reluctant if
black doesn't know the the line
precisely uh because then you think okay
can I capture here H do I really want to
give white the strong Center is is
Knight to E5 check anything at all
uh yeah those are the questions that um
uh is it Yen or Lena P has to answer
now and we have the standard ideas okay
uh so so the king of course will be
Castle King side the bishop might come
to to B2 probably A3 all depends on what
will be
played uh but yeah since the bishop is
on E7 the A3 no longer looks like such a
great Square even if D6 is played Bishop
A3
uh maybe just capturing and then go
going Bishop to B2 castless and bringing
our Knight into the game
so and also one of the uh one of the
strong points of the Evans Gambit is
that if your opponent isn't really sure
about uh how to how to approach these
positions they will they will burn a lot
of time okay uh saying that Knight to E5
is not a
problem
uh
yeah we're just going to capture
back we're just going to capture
back D6 has to be played you can't play
something like Knight F6 and allow E5 so
D6 has to be
played uh but now uh we uh by by
capturing on C3 black also now has to
worry about Knight to D5 in some line so
maybe also both D6 and C6 will will have
to be
played yeah uh but yeah our opponent is
okay so C6 first offering a queen trade
which we will not accept of course we're
not interested in that but now we have
to figure out if uh if the move order
matters if the move order matters here
or not
do we want to throw in a 95 check or or
or maybe it's just
uh not that
impressive yeah here we can even throw
in a queen to F5 check because the
bishop still hasn't been
developed
yeah we can throw in a queen F5 check
because if D6 uh if um the Knight blocks
we can play E5 and then D6 okay maybe
not the most precise but I I don't think
uh it should be a problem yeah we're
going to go Queen F5
check oh Bishop will
block
Bishop will block
really doesn't
uh yeah this doesn't look like it works
because E5 D6 attacks the queen we have
E6 check and then if Bishop captures we
have Knight G5 check the bishop is
locked so yeah E5 is just good here E5
is just
good
yeah the the idea was probably if D6
then I have to move my queen and then
captures on E5 but D6 is met with E6
here so that's uh probably the reason
why yeah you have to play D6 first
that's why you can't go for C6 first I
don't know I'm just guessing here but it
does appear that our opponent runs into
some trouble here
yeah it's
um always interesting The Adventures of
the events never
end and uh yeah okay we also okay so
does okay E6 we're going to go for E6
check and once the king moves we can
even just Castle King side so we don't
have to worry about any future Queen A5
action yeah now
just not not very impressive yeah King
goes
here do we throw in an in between move
or do we castle Yeah we Castle uh is
there anything we have to worry about
from our opponent no there isn't we're
just going to Castle
here uh if our Queen moves from pinning
the king then of course Bishop captures
Knight becomes a threat but for the
moment we don't have to worry about
it he could just capture captures and
then turn C3 uh but then the king is
just an f8 it doesn't look like uh
doesn't look like anything impressive
although it just might be the best way
to go yeah like captures captures
captures here Rook B8 goes after the B7
Pawn once
uh once that is taken care of we also
have some okay so no uh first
this and now where do we move that's the
question where do we
move
yeah we go back to D3
definitely since taking the Knight is
never uh any any good for black I mean
the leaving me with the dark Square
Bishop against the King on f8 doesn't
look like uh a very impressive thing to
do yeah okay Bishop captures play Rook
E1 put more pressure
here and once the bishop moves and I
don't know what's a good Square for the
bishop like F5 F5 okay is
nice yeah okay we don't
mind uh we're just going to move the
queen to E3 or do we have anything
better E3 is
fine
yeah okay now Knight to D5 might be
interesting but I don't mind giving up
the rook in in such a in such a fun line
I don't mind giving up the
Rook yeah it will be interesting uh
because we we have to finish the game
before we have to finish the game before
uh uh the The Rook gets into the
game okay so now Bishop captures on A1
of course oh No Just DE captures
oh oh I see what you're doing very
nice um yeah
sure sure sure
sure yeah but I don't think this uh
works out
very
well yeah the king will be very very
poorly placed there and now I have some
Bishop to A3 action here and also the
Rooks can come the Rooks will be
connected capturing again is
nothing Queen E8 or queen E7 is nothing
yeah it's
a
and he has to do something about the
bishop here and Bishop to G6 is just not
possible due to Knight E6 check winning
the queen and if he moves the Bishop
from this diagonal then just Rook B1 is
very strong yeah it's completely winning
for white I would I would say this is
like a plus four oh
really yeah I don't have Knight captures
on
F5 because
uh or he might just sacrifice the queen
like Queen D2 Queen captures Queen
captures Bishop
captures nah that's too that's too
much that's too much that even for me
that's too much even I wouldn't play
that yeah let's go
here I'm just going to pre-move this
just in case just in case uh it's played
I want to you know appear strong as if I
expected it some M tricks right
there okay now Bishop G6 uh is an option
but still Knight E6 check yeah I don't
know yeah we will have to we'll have to
bring the Rook into the game first sorry
the bishop The Rook by moving the bishop
like Bishop A3 followed by Rook
somewhere uh other than these two
squares as the bishop pair is very
strong uh much stronger than I I
expected
actually yeah okay so uh this is here uh
we're just going to play Bishop to A3
now or do we have any any in between
better moves no I don't think we do
let's go Bishop
A3 yeah and the king is still very sad
here so we're down two pawns but these
are two doubled pawns here so not really
something to worry
about and he still needs two moves like
Rook F7 is Rook F okay so he will go for
defending this but now now this is uh
this becomes an
option this definitely becomes an
option and we might even do it but not
just
yet let's ask him to give up the bishop
first
let's ask him to give up the dark Square
Bishop
first just putting some extra pressure
here yeah and on the other hand it all
of this could actually be fine for black
but I mean try playing this is is
disgusting you have to burn so much time
figuring out how to how to develop and
uh yeah it's not not fun
okay Bishop
E4 now the bishop is pinned how does
that work for
us how does that work for
us okay so now the Knight is no longer
defended yeah that's actually an
interesting
move actually an interesting
move
huh yeah that's a very nice move
huh not bad yeah not
bad not
bad yeah F3 now would be a big blunder
so my my brain should be punished just
for thinking about that now let's just
play Rook a
D1 but then he has like Queen A4 maybe
attacking the Knight and this but no
then we have this yeah Rook ad1 we have
to play it it's not a move I want to
play but it's a move I have to play now
Queen F5 for example no that uh no he
unpins here simply unpinning yeah what a
what a gentlemanly way to
play all right so we get our Rook into
the game first first things
first let's get the The Rook into the
game now he might have some Bishop E5
but I'm not worried about
that yeah the the defensive resources
here are are
evident yeah we're going to put the
queen
here sort of paralyze the queen a little
bit
and still the story of the of the poor
Rook that cannot
develop and now I might even consider a
move like F4 I'm not going to play it
I'm just going to consider it since uh
opening up this diagonal would be would
be pretty bad I
think yeah
Okay now what's the best way way to
continue yeah the Knight no longer is a
powerful piece
here so I'm guessing we just REM
maneuver the
Knight we REM maneuver the
Knight yeah let's go
here okay going after F2 but that's not
really a
threat
not really a serious threat or
anything can even play F3 here since uh
the D4 square is covered yeah F3 is
fine we can even take here now because
we also get to take this depending on
where the light Square Bishop goes like
if the light squ Bishop goes to G6 we
can even take
F5 yeah I just have to check I'm not
blundering anything otherwise it's
completely winning and he does have 12
seconds on the clock but I think yeah
just Rook captures on E5 is sufficient
Rook captures Pawn captures Bishop
captures Rook whatever
captures uh yeah probably Queen captures
if King captures we have this and if
Queen captures we just pick up the D5
Pawn threatening Rook d8 yeah we just
take and we take
here
and we take here if Queen captures yeah
if Queen captures we take here it's a
nice way to do it also we prevent check
and the next we pick up the queen yeah
that's
it all right so was a bit uh you know
give or take uh but let's uh let's check
out what what we did that could have
been done better but yeah okay 32 moves
you've seen uh even though okay some of
you are always saying yeah the Gambit is
bad don't play the EV Gambit but uh it's
hard to defend I
mean uh your opponent will really have
to burn a lot of time to get through the
moves all right so this is the standard
position of the Evans Gambit
B5 uh I played D4 and the immediate
Queen to B3 which is fine you could also
go for some other
moves uh Bishop captures on F7 I played
Queen to A4 and okay this is basically
the starting position of this line uh
and you can see that already the uh
engine gives this as a mistake uh that
should should be met with Queen D5 check
not the uh not the recapture but okay
basically captures and queen D5 check is
uh plus 1.2 for white so yeah curing not
the not the best for black now C6 Queen
F5 check sort of Queen to A4 a little
bit better uh okay just for future
references yeah don't go for any
unnecessary checks here it's still fine
for white but grabbing hold of this
diagonal is the way to go Queen F5
Bishop F6 E5 d six and now I played this
check oh and
the the real move is actually Queen F4
sort of but yeah it's still like a 0.5
nothing spectacular and now what's the
what's the deal here okay you just
capture and after the king moves you
just Castle so okay nice nice position
for white but okay I played this uh
point being that if he captures Knight
to G5 check wins me the piece since the
bishop here is spinned uh he moved I
played the castles and now Knight to E7
yeah sort of saying Black's out of the
woods but uh yeah it really didn't feel
like Black's Out of the Woods Knight D5
yeah okay I give up the rook and my
opponent played correctly C captur on D5
I played Knight to D4 Queen E8 Yeah we
actually played uh the top moves here
and I play Bishop to A3 Knight captures
on F5 also possible I play Bishop to A3
rook d8 and now yeah know now sort of
Rook a to C1 just uh taking care of all
of my Rook issues I played Queen to F4
first First bishop to E4 and
now okay I played Rook to D1 since the
bishop is pinned did I realize this in
the game or did I yeah no I think in the
game I I forgot that the bishop was
pinned I was talking about F3 Bishop
captures here but yeah I play Rook ad1
King f8 and I played Rook to E3 uh which
uh is obviously the losing move for me
wow yeah Queen A4 but I thought I can
play it because the Rook guards the
bishop oh but Queen A4 comes with an
attack on The Rook here and a double
attack on the Knight wow that's super
sad that's super sad and I would have to
give up uh yeah I'd have to give up
material here in order to survive this
yeah uh Dodge the Dodge the bullet there
Queen H4 uh and now again H6 yeah saying
that the position of my queen is not
very
impressive
uh yeah first H6 before removing the
bishop Rook to
f8 I played Knight E2 okay and now F3
yeah now it's so we're again uh in Dr
territory but yeah now Bishop F5 uh
blunders the game due to the tactic that
we played uh but it's still possible to
play with Bishop F6 Queen G3 and Rook C2
yeah I was looking at Bishop C2 without
the the bishop F6 move and now okay Rook
C8 so yeah with this okay you still play
it uh but our opponent misplayed it with
the bishop to F5 I played Rook captures
and now it's uh yeah game over
uh so yeah I mean it's it's what we
expected uh it was a nice game I
blundered with that Rook to E3 move my
opponent retaliated with a blunder of
his own and I was able to win the game
but you've seen how time issue was a
problem and it's uh very often is when
facing the gam if you haven't studied it
at all I always like to remind people
actually played it U long long time ago
maybe some 13 years ago maybe even 15
against the candidate master in the uh
creation championship and I played the
B4 and
he he he did not believe that I played
it in a classical game and he spent the
next 45 minutes uh contemplating uh how
to how to properly defend in the end he
defeated me uh but it was not the the
the problem of the opening he he
misplayed the opening but I just
misplayed the game uh point being that
you should always uh uh you know be be
ready for it even if you don't like
playing it yourself you should know how
to how to properly defend against
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very nice uh that I was
able to include another victory for the
Evans Gambit as it is the greatest
opening ever played so you know we'll
we'll see what happens in the next one
uh on our way to that 2300 and then
we'll see what happens then uh so yeah
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day